our keynote is tardy at Holmgren he's an
economist by training and he's the
executive director of the Stockholm
International Water Institute that helps
inform decision-makers of Smart Water
policy and sustainable development he
was an ambassador at the Swedish
ministry for Foreign Affairs and head of
the department of poor development
policy and he was responsible policies
are in global sustainable development he
also served as Serpa for the UN
Secretary General's high-level panel on
global sustainability and he served at
the on the board of directors in the
research department of the World Bank
the title of his talk is organizing to
combat the global water crisis yeah
thanks a lot and I have the privilege to
wrap up this most interesting conference
and before sharing with you some
thoughts of how to combat the global
water crisis in the future I will start
by bringing you 760 years back in time
that is a time in 2012 52 and Stockholm
the capital city of Sweden in
Scandinavia was established and founded
when Stockholm is based and also located
at the mouth of a freshwater lake in the
Baltic Sea and it's a very a good
location both of security matters and
trade but also water wise so over the
years
Stockholm expanded immigration from the
countryside but when we entered into the
1800s the city was one of the most
unhealthy places to live in at least
when it comes to cities in Europe we had
cholera epidemics mortality rates higher
than the birth rate you know at that
time most more or less half of the
population of Sweden emigrated over here
so today they're more Swedish ancestors
the u.s. than Swedes in Sweden and so
that the city was quite bad shape so
something has to be done to reactivate
that so a slow change took place from
the 1850s onwards well we learn more
about the connection between dirty water
and health there was also a law
introduced and compulsory school in
primary school in Sweden
knowledge about the benefit of
hand-washing and this three elements
ideas about how to handle water
schooling and hand-washing by a number
of years increased life expectancy by
ten years so that was a very crucial
decisions and knowledge-based directions
in the mid and late 18-hundreds and
first Water Works were invested in in
nineteen eighty sixty one and eventually
coming into the twentieth century also
wastewater treatment plants so there was
an improvement in access to clean
drinking water that meant better health
development took place or more water and
Water Works and wastewater works and the
core idea was the integrator and by
mental social and economic aspects even
maybe City Council and people at that
time didn't pronounce it in that way but
that was the essence of what took place
so by a late twentieth century we had a
quite successful achievement when it
came to the water situation in in in the
capital city we at that time we merged
the wastewater treatment and also the
waterworks into one a public company
stock calm water incorporated with the
mission to make stock on one of the
cleanest cities in the world in terms of
water and sanitation and success factors
behind that was of course we have a
access to high quality raw water supply
I mentioned this freshwater lake which
is just at the shores of calm we also
have a when organization handling both
water and wastewater a lot of
interaction between policymakers and
researchers performance indicators were
introduced and also a cost recovery
funding base for running this and this
meant and led to that today we can fish
and swim in the city center
you can see if you come to Stockholm
summertime people arguing Selman outside
the Royal cows and you can have for your
dinner meal and you can swim etc so it's
now one of the cleanest cities in the
world at least when the company capital
cities when it comes to water well that
was the beginning of what we
celebrate as the annual World Water Week
in Stockholm in the late 20th century
1991 we introduced the international
scientific symposium on global water
issues
the Stockholm water symposium now we
have the World Water Week a full weekend
of August early September every year
where we gather some 2006 700
participants lost it was from 130
countries coming to Stockholm we have a
mix of government officials researchers
ministers civil society non-government
organizations etc and also businessman
or businesswoman nowadays and that is to
exchange ideas and foster solutions and
learn from each other and develop new
solutions and this year it will sorry
yeah it will yeah at the time on this
talk on well what we closed have some
prize ceremonies we do award the stock
converter price which the king of Sweden
is the patron Amon it's also gonna do
better
top pictures are from out of the hands
of the King today to the winner
organisation or a person they also had
at this lower part they stopped in dunya
water price and that is Frances Victoria
and she spent some time here at Yale so
she's aware of of Yale as well as very
interested in in water and work-related
issues now this year the Water Week will
take place first week of September
dealing with which is the International
Year award cooperation water cooperation
in building partnerships next year we
will focus on energy and water we had
food food security in water last year
and in 2015 we go for water and
development well that's for an
introduction
the Stockholm Institute or the Stockholm
International Water Institute was
established in 1991 at the time of the
water symposium was established and we
have a mission of a water-wise world we
are a policy oriented Institute policy
making Institute also be research on we
are known for profit politically neutral
Institute a foundation nowadays with
some 60 staff members from more as 20
countries working in Stockholm
we are supported by the government of
Sweden the city of Stockholm but
mainland for most we do run programs and
activities and projects worldwide funded
by donors governments agencies yogin
World Bank and others and we do focus on
five areas and I think all areas have
been related to or discussed today water
governance transboundary water climate
change and water water food and energy
and water economics and I will now focus
on four of this area that water in
energy water and food
transboundary water and climate motor
from the perspectives of the Gabonese
and an economics field let me start off
just a short picture her on the global
water use well this is average figures
but we know that fresh water and amount
according to estimates will be out state
by outstrips sustainable supplied by the
by the year 2030 by 40%
so that is maybe the starting point of
what we could call the looming crisis
today more as an average global food
production is about calculated for
estimated steak some 70% of the global
water withdrawals energy sector 20% and
households 10% on food there is a
paradox there is today enough food to
feed all people of the world I often
call too if pre International Food
Policy Research Institute in Washington
DC to ask Shannon found what is a
cetacean enough food is produced and
actually more food is produced and it's
consumed and that is a paradox in itself
today almost 1/3 of all food produced
worldwide is not eaten or consumed in
our part of the world in the northern
hemisphere we do waste we don't eat all
food that is produced in low-income
countries food produce is not coming to
the table because due to bad
infrastructure new storage etc so we
know that healthy investments in taking
place in food
action and at the end of the day some 30
to 40 percent it's not even even
consumed up or eaten and I don't know
any other sector in our society economy
that produced hundred percent or
something and then it then is not
consumed so that is a real challenge and
if you do consider all investments they
can place any device human resources and
water that and goes into that production
then you will have a real challenge and
we know that today food production
continues to rise but still almost 1
billion people are hungry or under the
poverty line we have some another 200
billion 2 billion that are
undernourished and as a matter of fact
one problem is also in 1 billion 1.5
billion overeat and that is also
something that we that we know also
notice in in what used to be developing
countries but what are we called
middle-income countries so the scarcity
of water in the food production supply
chain could also be seen from a
geographic approach where we knew that
more or less half of the world
population lives between the 20th and
40th latitude north of the equator but
only 1/8 of world population lives south
of the equator
Aminu that in between the 20th and 40th
latitude we on average have some 500
millimeter precipitation on an annual
basis only one harvest and I think that
is one reason why we do see more and
more what is labeled land acquisitions
nowadays that you need to go to places
where there is watering and availability
to produce food and even if today only
10 percent of all food produced
worldwide is traded in between states I
think that isn't a figure that will
increase in the future but in this
category or in this in this part of the
world we have also most of the world's
related poverty and development
challenges and
this moose populated latitudes are also
the scariest on water so we hurry we'll
have a real problem your graphic wise
but also when it comes to production of
of staple foods now it's Friday
afternoon and it's time to see some film
so I will show you a favor
worldwide one-third of our food is lost
or wasted 1.3 billion tons of food are
thrown away each year leading to an
incalculable waste of water energy and
investments with repercussions for land
and people ships around the globe dude
is increasingly demanded far from where
it was grown
wherever waste occurs it brings
resources that are growing scarce around
the world tossing out an apple is
equivalent to seven times the water
flush down the toilet
if one liter of milk is thrown away in
effect it's much more than just a liter
it's about what a thousand liters of
water needed for the cows and to grow
there be
since roughly three times more food
comes from rain-fed agriculture the true
misuse of water is much greater the food
waste in North America Europe alone
could eat all of the world's hungry
three times over but food waste is a
global issue in prosperous societies
food is wasted on a staggering scale at
the retail and consumer levels where it
is in developing countries this similar
amount is lost due to lack of storage
facilities marketing arrangements and
insufficient transparent
what kind of corporate management's
would accept 33% in annual Watson's
different challenges require different
solutions in this local rules we oughta
scrutinize inconsistent standards such
as best before dates support corporate
initiatives reconsidered trade and labor
legislation and give more for to
sustainable diets a global scale
overeating is much more common than
under nutrition and has implications for
demand as well as in developing
countries and Greek cultural
infrastructure and transport must be
improved to enhance access to markets
this will benefit farmers as well as
consumers as a global community you
share existing needs or resources as a
source of life but increasingly we are
going to share their scarcity to our
global water resources are limited and
variable
they might not keep up with population
growth and people's choices of balance
the pressure of fresh water resources is
severe even more so in the course of
climate change with food waste also
plays a role
agriculture accounts for a significant
contribution to greenhouse gas emissions
an estimated 10 percent of global
warming is being cold solely by our
waste of food
growing food needs plenty of energy but
it takes many times their energy to
process cook and refrigerate food as a
consequence the waste of resources is
even worse when we throw away packaged
already cooked food but worst of all is
when we throw away meat one kilogram of
meat calls for up to ten times more
water than the same weight in cereal
brains most of this water is used to
grow animal feed an excessive demand for
food obtains from animals increasingly
swallowed up water and land but you see
one single hamburger for instance uses
up 2,400 liters of water with the meat
part accounting for 2,200 liters with
each burger a stack of 16 bathtubs full
of water is consumed
from beautiful our food supply chain has
lots of leaks before producing even more
let's run an efficiency check post by
reducing food losses and waist
overeating and an excessive demand for
meat that will not only be more food to
feed the hungry we would win backwater
soil fertility and energy to multiple
wins are within reach and without
sacrificing
yeah yeah look at some of the possible
solutions or at least investments that
he'd be done in developing countries or
low-income countries on my side I may
say investment in more efficient
infrastructure in the food supply chain
so a lot of activities outside the water
sector itself needs to be taken mainly
infrastructure investments in
high-income countries is to waste less
food and keep more balanced diet in the
future and common for all parts of the
world is to look at more efficient use
of water in the food production supply
chain which means that there is a need
of incentive system and I think
valuation or pricing if you may of water
as it's believed to be free free good
but that is one part of them to solve
the water overuse and scarcity of water
roles in the food production chain let
us now turn to water and energy it has
been said number occasion during this
conference that there is a very close
relationship and lead the linkages
between water and energy we know we need
water to extract and refine energy for
hydropower thermoelectric cooling fuel
production in a number of senses and
energy is also crucial for water waste
water treatment energy associated reduce
the water drinking water treatment
extraction and transmission and I
believe that a lot of what we pay as a
consumer today for water is actually the
energy input into the water not the
water itself as a good but the water
content the energy so what is the
central component in the energy mix we
know we know at the same time that any
demand is growing rapidly with increased
GDP per capita number of countries in
the world high living standards etc
there is a forecast that energy demand
will grow by 50% just in 20 years time
at the same time as with with the food
we know that 1.6 billion lack access to
electricity and another one point four
billion lack access to modern fuel for
cooking heating a lightning so but we
also know that water and energy policies
have been developed more or less in
isolation and I think there is a great
need for the two communities to come
together because they do depend on each
other and one paradox series and one
very problematic I will say also
challenge is that what I also like
elaborating upon a bit on the food
production list is the pricing there are
so different mechanism while energy is
priced on the market you know hour by
hour what you pay for your energy bill
you can in your house or in your house
or in dwelling see exactly what you have
consumed in energy what water is not
it's a human right it's a public good
and how do you value water right with
with that Kanto nation and that is a
real challenge because as in the
production chain today we don't value
water at its right cost we also have
other challenges without the costing we
have the the shale gas oil sands the the
fracking what does that mean impact on
water resources an environment we have
also huge demand for water in new
efficient cooling technique technologies
for poverty production you know what
also what the former panel told us a bit
about the the competition between by
your energy versus food production and
what I mentioned just before the real
value how do you value water at it's
it's it's right cost or value for
production of energy so pricing of water
I think is of a sense when it comes to
to the mix or the linkages between water
and energy transparent reporter another
field that I would like to raise it's
what we deal with when it comes to
countries or regions their share the
same River Basin could be lakes it could
be aquifers and this map shows us
and you that huge part of the world is
dependent on Chad Raber or share water
sources as a matter of fact 75% of all
countries in the world is our appearance
in shredder River Basins there are some
200 countries I think human has 192
members over 50% of all available
freshwater resources or insured river
basins and 33 countries which is more or
less
fourth of the globe's number of
countries have 95 percent or more of
their water in shale river basins and
when you're especially in arid regions
water and shared water is becoming a
national security issue so in the 80s
some 30 years ago water was and today
also is a source of conflict and we
believe that number of countries would
go to war over water resources and
boutros-ghali whose was done defense
minister in egypt claimed that next war
in the Middle East will be what water
and King Hussein of Jordan also said
that only reasonable to go again with
Israel is water but and that is some I
will show you some figure soon we
realized that on water you do tend
rather to cooperate than good armed
conflicts there are conflicts and the
number of a complex and as Peter
mentioned earlier on maybe the conflicts
are on the crease right now but mainly
our experience is that regions countries
do cooperate on water issues and why is
that well I think the connection to food
is obvious answer as you are in most
cases you would like to produce your own
food and if you don't have water you
cannot produce the food for for your
population in your country but then we
started more or less to increase our
trade on food supplies which means that
your import water erode and then produce
it yourself and this virtual water
is a key component in why we don't have
seen that many armed conflicts that you
could expect some 30 or 20 years ago and
we'd increased trade and work on food
you also import water in that sense and
even if the political rhetoric is there
it might be mainly more for the domestic
audience and we are engaged ourselves
more Institute in a number of
discussions in Jordan River Nile Basin
Mekong River and other places on a
technical level and that is most
interesting on technical level there
have been already in the most tense
situations between countries where your
code more or less foresee that there
should be a norm complex there is a
discussion often on a technical level
between water utilities and also on in
different regions on water cooperation
and that is some research I will show
you from from Oregon State University
involved that have have analyzed a
number of transparent reporter events
over quite a long time period and found
out that on the right hand side on the
blue bars that is the number of events
vendor you find kind of cooperation
rather than going to conflict on the
left-hand side the red bars or when you
go to the very far end it's armed
conflict and then you have different
connotations of conflict and going to
cooperation so we do see more a tendency
that countries and regions do cooperate
on water on shared water resources then
go to conflict but there is unless P
dimension there might be trend now that
we do see some more intrastate rather
than or in states rather than in between
states of leads so what can we do
possibly do when it comes to transparent
reporter well is to support as usual the
weaker part should it be country or
municipalities or regions and whatever
it is provinces in the negotiation
because this is a power game shared
water and transponder is a power if it's
political power or
in your analytical capacity etc you yeah
that is that is for sure
you could also provide as an outside
partner to a trans boundary water
relationship benefits identified the
benefits of cooperation because that is
also our experience when we do see that
countries to cooperate on water in ten
situations that could spill over to
other sectors of the of the society
economy as well so there is a there is a
benefit of water cooperation and
cooperation could be improved of course
itself now turn it to climate change on
water which has been the main focus of
discussions today I will take it from a
governance perspective on the global
level we know we have the climate change
negotiations the human effort it will
signal creations and as a matter of fact
I think that has been the conclusion
that climate change is about water we
see there is a close linkage also when
it comes to mitigation adaptation and
water is the link in this area as well
the Copenhagen Accord from 2009 decided
that by 2020 there is a need or there
should be fundraising by hundred billion
US dollars for low-income countries
developing countries for their
adaptation mitigation measures I think
that is a low figure the World Bank had
a estimate of some four hundred billion
a few years ago we have discussion going
on now worldwide on the post-2015
development agenda
you knew this Millennium Development
Goals are coming to an end two years
from now and they should be replaced for
something and in Rio de Janeiro last
year the Rio +20 conference it was
decided by the member states of United
Nations to to establish what this label
the sustainable development goals and
that is now being both discussed and
analyzed in a number of context all over
the world and I think there is water is
a key component in the SDG so the
sustainable development goals to come
now on on climate change that was the
global picture a lot of global focus on
discussions
even if people see the climate change
negotiations as wrong now let us also
look at the national local level which
cause climate change is a fact the facts
are in luke level i think the national
level is closely related and linked to
the global level often the negotiators
are also leading partners in their
national capacities so there are lot of
good national policies and strategies of
high quality but then we do see melissa
disconnect the local level at the local
level you often and may be mainly in
low-income countries and middle-income
countries you lack capacity your lack
resources and you don't have that close
linkage to the to the national level and
I think that is a challenge how to
ensure implementation of national policy
strategies at the local level and how to
learn from the local level building into
new national strategies often national
studies tend to relate maybe more to the
global biggest discussions and to the to
the specific context in the at the local
level we have this transferring of funds
how could that be done in efficient way
from the international to the national
to the local level and also which is key
her always when you do have huge
transfer of funds how to ensure
transparency accountability and prevent
corruption in them in the in the
utilization of those funds let me give
you an example of the local level from
Vietnam this guy and this person was on
this photo he shows where he has a water
level rise more or less on annual basis
and he is a former in the Mekong Delta
and nowadays we know that in the Mekong
Delta you have saltwater intrusion
more than 70 kilometers up the Delta
which is also a huge problem for rice
farmers and what kind of support can can
he and his family get and what should
they do and I think he has three options
the first one is this is on
no memories household income the percent
of household income from agriculture on
the vertical axis you have market access
if the household income of agriculture
is decrease the states as it is he might
hang in step up or step out well if
there is and you have the influence of
increasing climate variability and
change also coming there so he could be
the good adaptation policy of course
step up produce more food and also stay
as a farmer but if that doesn't happen
he might as you know die see also he and
his family maybe decide to migrate move
into the city to the urban areas and we
know that more or less half of the world
population nowadays live in urban areas
or he could also hang around with his
farming on the lower level than before
nowadays Vietnam is the second largest
rice exporter in the world and and to
keep that export of course they need to
also to adapt to the what I mentioned
about that the climate change effects
taking place now with the saltwater
intrusion and also to have the
possibility to continue to grow rice at
the fields that in this picture shows an
area in the mekong delta where you do
have flooding regularly but the problem
is when it's sea or saltwater coming in
that is not possible than to to to grow
rice and longer it will also affect the
groundwater so in climate change in the
government governance perspective well
link
national policies more closely to the
local policies ensure that they are
complement each other learn on and build
on from the local level and strengthen
the capacity at the local level I think
these are some of the key concerns for
the future of climate change
so overall conclusions of these four
areas for the food production well in
our part of the world reduce losses
reduce waste I mean and also in the
developing countries reduce losses I
think smart investments and change of
attitude is needed energy I think
pricing or valuation of water is a key
component here to improve the allocation
of scarce water resources that goes also
for other areas not only for energy but
I think that is it one of the main
challenges for water and water community
in the future on trans boundary well
identified benefits of cooperation so
you don't end into armed conflicts and
support the weaker parts in those in
those transparent areas where you might
have a conflict or an armed conflict
around the corner and then climate
change when it comes to governance
issues connect the global and national
policies more to the local policies and
build on a strength and the local
knowledge and support so thank you very
much